soldiers from South Sudan's opposition
celebrate their return to the capital
Juba it's a historic moment for these
men who haven't set foot in the town
since the conflict first erupted their
arrival brings hope that the peace
process is finally taking hold when I go
out I don't bite first but now I come by
this problem but despite the optimism
tensions are running high amid regular
ceasefire violations and concerns that
government and opposition forces might
clash again to avoid confrontations the
government army the SPLA pledged to move
most of its troops outside the city
something the opposition says hasn't
been done well come and see our forces
you know the number that arrived today
we have ordered a revolution we show to
you the forces but for the for the SPLA
tangata still inside the the box
everything is still intact you can see
when the detachment the forces are
deployed all over the city the
government on the other hand claims it
has completed the withdrawal of forces
to sites such as this one located at
least 25 kilometers outside of Juba but
this has yet to be verified by
independent monitors we have a total of
nine deployment sites this is just one
of them so we sent out an invitation to
that monitoring mechanism telling them
that desperella is ready for
verification
despite the cautious optimism
surrounding much ours returned many
South Sudanese don't really trust that
peace is really coming over 28,000
displaced persons mostly from Achara
snow air tribe are still seeking safety
inside this camp on the outskirts of
Juba guarded by United Nations
peacekeepers we are very happy to
receive Riek Machar and we are happy to
see the opposition forces here but we
don't really know what will happen after
he comes back if there will really be
Pease much ours return is just the first
step on the long road towards reforms
reconstruction and ultimately
reconciliation of communities that have
been torn apart by the conflict until
that happens many inside this UN camp
don't trust their country is safe enough
to return home